وأنت تخرج إلى المطار ، إنه
نوع من الاشمئزاز حقًا مدى كثافة
الدخان هنا فقط ، يمكنك شم رائحته
في الهواء كثيفة جدًا حقًا مزعجة للغاية ، لقد قمت
برحلة على متن طائرة
لتكون قادرًا على رؤية مكان
الحرائق بالضبط.  الأصعب
وعندما تضربهم ، غالبًا ما يكون من
الصعب للغاية رؤية الحرائق
نفسها في
تجربتي الأولى ، كان الدخان
كثيفًا لدرجة أننا لم نتمكن من رؤية المظلة
أسفل موريس بارني ، فهذه هي
المقبرة تقريبًا لأن كل ما يمكنك رؤيته قد مات
[  موسيقى]
بينما قد تعتقد أن منطقة
الأمازون بأكملها عبارة عن شعلة ، فليس هذا هو الحال ،
فإن الحرائق الجديدة متقطعة ،
فإنها تدمر مساحات شاسعة من الأرض
بسرعة كبيرة ، وهناك رياح تهب
بحرارة جافة شديدة في كل مكان ويمكن أن
يكون من الصعب جدًا اكتشافها  ولكن عندما تراهم ، لا
يوجد أي خطأ في الشخص الذي
سافرت إليه ، أعني أن هذا نوع طبيعي
من الحرق أو أننا نشاهد شيئًا مجنونًا ،
فهذا ليس طبيعيًا ، إنه مجنون تمامًا
خاصة في هذا الوقت منك
تمثل موارد [الموسيقى] مشكلة هنا ، فأنت تعلم أن
صور الأقمار الصناعية قادرة على الاحتفاظ
بعلامة تبويب أكبر حول مدى انتشار الضرر الذي
يمثل الكثير من المعلومات المضللة والكثير من
السياسات التي تقف وراء المكان الذي تتواجد فيه الحرائق بالضبط
تساعد الآن بشكل سيئ
[الموسيقى]
[الموسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
تكمن المشكلة في كونها بعيدة
جدًا لدرجة يصعب معها التعامل مع
ما توقف حرق ما توقف
وبالتالي لا يزال هناك قلق بشأن
ما سيحدث بعد ذلك